RYAN MATSUMOTO: Hi.
My name is Ryan, and
I'd like to show you
how to get started with
Google Cloud at no charge.
In the next few
minutes, we'll talk
about how you can get
started with the free trial,
the free tier, and Google
Maps Platform monthly credits.
Ready?
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As you start exploring
Google Cloud,
you may want to take advantage
of our 90-day, $300 free trial.
The free trial provides you
with free Cloud billing credits
to pay for resources used while
you learn about Google Cloud.
You can activate the free
trial if you've never
been a paying customer of
Google Cloud, Google Maps
Platform, or Firebase, and
if you haven't previously
signed up for the free trial.
To start, visit
console.cloud.google.com
to open the Google
Cloud Console.
This is where you can manage
your Google Cloud resources
directly from the web.
Log in with the Google
account of your choice
and accept the terms
and conditions.
At the top of your
screen, you see
a banner about the free trial.
Click Activate to continue.
Select your country,
tell us what
best describes your
organization or needs,
and accept the terms of service.
Then click Continue.
After verifying
your phone number,
choose between a
Business account
or an Individual account.
Then you're asked to provide
credit card information.
But don't worry.
You won't be charged
unless you manually upgrade
to a paid account later on.
Click Start my free
trial to activate it.
Now you have $300 in free
credits for the first 90 days
to use across all
of Google Cloud.
You can do things like
create new Compute Engine
virtual machines, deploy
serverless applications
to Cloud Run, and set up new
Cloud SQL database instances.
Throughout the
free trial period,
your available credits
and days remaining
are displayed in the billing
section of the Google Cloud
Console.
And, if you upgrade to
a paid account later on,
you'll be able to keep
your Cloud resources
and use any remaining credits.
Beyond the free
trial, there's also
the free tier, which lets
you use certain Google Cloud
products free of charge within
specified monthly usage limits.
The free tier is available to
both new and existing users
and includes products
like App Engine, BigQuery,
Cloud Functions, Cloud
Vision, Firestore, and more.
With BigQuery, for example,
you get 10 gigabytes
of storage per month and 1
terabyte of querying per month.
If you're using the
free trial, any usage
of products within
the free tier will not
be deducted from your
$300 free trial credits.
And, if you've already
upgraded to a paid account,
any usage of products
within the free tier
will not be charged
to your credit card.
Finally, the Google
Cloud free program
includes $200 of monthly
credits to use with Google Maps
Platform products.
This allows you
to explore and use
powerful APIs for maps,
routes, and places.
So there you have it, an
overview of how you can get
started with Google
Cloud at no charge
using the free trial, the free
tier, and Google Maps Platform
credits.
Make sure to check out the
other episodes of "Google Cloud
Essentials," where we
cover the Google Cloud
Console, the Google Cloud
SDK, key use cases, and more.
I can't wait to see what
you build with Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]